so you've got your cult leader which is
Trump and then you've got your cult
members who are the trumpists who go to
the rallies there was a rally in Texas
over the weekend we already looked at
clips of Donald Trump speaking check out
some of these interviews one of the
funniest things to me is when someone
repeats some conspiracy theory and they
don't even really understand it and it's
sort of like whatever whatever the
conspiracy theory is I believe it and
here's a guy who says listen they stole
it was either one million or a hundred
million votes in Texas and of course
Texas doesn't have a population of 100
million how could you steal 100 million
votes doesn't really matter check this
out he said there was the could turn
blue she said that two years ago so if
they cheat which Mike Lindell said there
was a hundred million million vote
stolen yeah there were there was a
hundred million or a million votes
stolen in Texas now one of those numbers
is of course mathematically impossible
but it doesn't matter to these people
they just you know I I hate to do this I
really do because I sometimes I think
adopting the language of the right
doesn't make sense but they talk about
they love to say that there's leftists
who are NPCs non-player characters these
are just like the background characters
in video games we just they just repeat
stuff they don't do anything they repeat
do the same motion and over and over
again that's what these people I don't
know Lindell said it was like 100
million votes were stolen in Texas maybe
one million I don't know but clearly it
happened here's a woman who raises mules
yes who raises mules and she drove 17
hours to the rally opened the people's
eyes to the corruption in this
government he did more than any
president in the history of this country
by the way she raises mules
it's my 30th rally bro 17 hours
got here Wednesday I'm from east
Tennessee understand another
uh characteristic another trait of Cults
and cult members
who is willing to go the farthest
literally and furthest figuratively
to please and show Devotion to the cult
leader
here's a guy at the rally explaining
that the biblical principles that Trump
adheres to are why he loves Trump the
biblical principles that Trump Embraces
is what really uh what I really like
about him I've never heard another
president invoke the name of God and
Jesus more than I've heard president
Donald Trump J Trump and that's the the
main thing for me is that he's embracing
biblical principles and follow the Bible
and you can't go wrong yeah
um now it is true that Trump will invoke
the Bible frequently of course he does
it only as the most obvious form of of
uh pandering and we say who could
possibly fall for that well that guy
fell for it that guy fell for it uh the
leader of Latinos for Trump I don't even
know if that's real she says God sent
her to the rally to deliver a very
important message to Donald Trump are
all of these people merely mentally ill
no I don't think so I think it's it's
radicalized politics in some cases
combined with mental illness and by the
way couldn't God deliver the message to
Trump himself why didn't he did he need
this lady the message for Trump I I have
a message from the Lord for him and I'm
I need to get that message to him to
tell him that he is to call this nation
to fast pray and repent including
himself and all the leaders even Faith
leaders because God wants his people
back and he wants Trump back and Trump
used to surround himself with faith
leaders and then covet hit and he was
separated from Faith leaders right that
was the real tragedy of covet Trump was
separated from all of the pastors and
you know um he thinks he's fighting
flesh and he's actually fighting a
bigger in a bigger realm that he maybe
doesn't understand or no one's explained
it to him and I don't know if he's
surrounded around people that just won't
let us get this message to him but it's
important for that I've been traveling
the United States identifying those
leaders that can be assembled that
understand yeah well she's going to give
us that list and we'll examine how many
of those people should be in prison
um a guy at the rally said that he was
in Washington DC on January 6th he knows
exactly what antifa looks like and it
was definitely antifa what did you see
that day
I saw lots of antifa and I know how she
recognized them in a crowd I was out on
the west coast I was like a big Burning
Man festival person so I've seen these
antifa scum I know what they look like I
smelled a rat I didn't get anywhere
close to the Capitol because I was gonna
wait and see uh what it was gonna be
like let's also not forget her everyone
forgets Roseanne Boylan if I ever have a
daughter I'm gonna name her Roseanne
after Roseanne boil it and of course
Roseanne Barr the other greatest
American Roseanne Barr Roseanne Bar all
right okay yeah it's all getting kind of
a little bit weird
um one guy was asked what's the thing
you love the most about Trump here's his
answer what is the one thing you loved
about President Trump
um
just not caring about what other people
think and getting respect from other
countries now respect me more yeah the
truth is respect for the U.S was at a
historic low under Trump and these folks
just they they refuse to acknowledge
that or they don't care
um and then here is a January 6
defendant trennis Evans who was one of
the people in Nancy Pelosi's office he
says he coordinated with the Trump team
to do the national anthem hearing that
you LED this effort with Donald Trump
tonight to sing the Star-Spangled Banner
talk about it yeah we have been pushing
uh actually I came up with this idea on
Wednesday and I started pushing kind of
late in the game here asking do we
started through social media pushes we
reached into the president's Camp
everywhere we could I'm a j6 defendant
myself so uh reached into the camp
everywhere we could just saying in
solidarity with these guys yeah he's a
j6 defendant and of course we need to
show our solidarity with the rioters why
I don't know but we need to these are
these are obviously delusional people
but these are dangerous people and it
should not be I mean listen I hate to do
something so crass but remember with the
Manson cult
um they were not just followers
they were activated to become murderers
and the cultists can be just as or more
dangerous than the leader
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 percent
home compostable which means they break
down in weeks rather than decades they
don't fill up our landfills they don't
pollute our oceans they're zip seal
kitchen bags come in sandwich or gallon
bag sizes to fit your needs and the best
part about hold on bags is they work I
use them at home they're just as good as
all of the name brand bags you fill them
up they stretch and they don't break
everybody uses trash bags and freezer
bags if you care about the planet you
can do something by using hold on bags
instead and it's a really easy way to do
your part to shop plant-based bags and
replace single-use Plastics all over
your home go to hold on bags.com and
you'll save twenty percent with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below